alter alter alter was ist das denn bitte
war was ist das alter was ist das was
ist etwas ist das für roter stein
hey leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge hero ich will eigentlich mit
tadel aufnehmen dann gehe ich mit dem in
ein gespräch
dann sagt er mir in dem gespräch hey ich
ja noch ein video hoch und hält mich da
ist die ganze zeit auf und dann ach ja
dass dort noch zwei stunden also wir
können zwei stunden auf nämlich so fick
dich alter jetzt nehme ich halt alleine
auf eventuelle ist die nächste folge mit
tadel ich muss auf jeden fall jetzt mal
langsam wieder zurückkommen das hier ist
die welt ein bisschen aufbauen mache ich
mal den sound auch hier ein bisschen
lauter letzte folge war ja relativ
chaotisch mitre wie allerdings habe ich
jetzt endlich meine einen weg gefunden
wie irgendwie was zu essen zu holen was
auch alle geschrieben haben
luca toni zu einem cup coup hier ist
überall gras und du kannst ja an
pflanzen habe dass mir zu umständlich
und du kannst auch hasen töten das
wusste ich nicht
also danke danke dass ihr da so viel so
viel hilft auf jeden fall was ich denn
da hinten rum und macht dass dieser
komische pelikan oder was es ist ich
denke jetzt aber erst mal übrigens auch
für viele meinten
lukas dessen existenz ach so lukat
existenz ist auch irgendwie so was was
man was ich nehmen kann und dann teilt
das irgendwie watt aber ich bin mir noch
nicht sicher und das ist dass die sal
das ist gewiss alles was man machen kann
weiß ich auch nicht aber ich bin hier in
der ghezal gilde von den anderen drin
deswegen muss man schauen bringt und
davor dass auch diese komischen blätter
teilchen das leben so viele leute
kommentare geschrieben ich wert darauf
jetzt noch nicht eingehen sondern erst
wenn ich dann auch dazu in der nächsten
folge dann wahrscheinlich wenn ich dann
erstmal wieder zu hause bin weil dieser
folge möchte jetzt nur nach hause laufen
ich habe auch gedacht ich könnte mir
theoretischen und links holen entfärbt
schirm und dann könnte ich mit dem pferd
schirmen das ist gold glaub ich ja das
ist gold gold ist wertvoll dass alten ja
egal ich holte mir erst mal meine sachen
zurück welche richtig mit dem fertigen
jahr zurück reisen oder ich mache
einfach ein brötchen damit ich halt
nicht so viel hunger colin verbrauchern
dann mache ich mir wenn ich wieder zu
hause bin fällt da ist noch so eine
feder und zwar meinten dass noch gold zu
halten einige dass ich dir wieder mit
gold ein kräuseln kann dann habe ich in
so eine bestimmte fehler was wir haben
eine sache
da was genau das für eine feder ist
könnt ihr mir halt wie gesagt alles in
die kommentare schreiben
das ist irgendwie gold um das nochmal
diamanten gold um eine federung oder
irgendwie sowas und dann bin ich der
barbar in sachen alter was soll das denn
kann es sein dass items nicht dies
brunnen
hey sie behindert meine eitel sind
einfach alle noch da also die vom
letzten mal
hey junge wie geil und er ist meine
kiste jetzt auch noch da oder was da ist
meine kiste wenn die sachen voll sind
alter da habe ich ja gar nichts verloren
hat das abgeholt wird ihm wegen dem ich
erst mal ein bisschen am besten ich
bräuchte eigentlich wirklich so eine art
backpack aber das sehr schwer zu kriegen
oder gibt es überhaupt den hexen also
wie gesagt kommentarfunktion könnt ihr
euch so ausnutzen
ich bin übrigens auch zur zeit immer so
viel am kommentare beantworten
das e mail da wirklich so viel schreiben
können das ist unglaublich eigentlich zu
denen schmerbeck feder behalte ich erst
mal ich sortiere das jetzt mal ganz grob
die bulls kann ja alles decken tust du
scheiß egal feier lockt hier da habe ich
genug davon
ich nehme jetzt davon etwa die
wichtigsten kommt die unnötigste sachen
schmeißt jetzt mal weg knochen kann ich
mir knochen mehr ausmachen und dann
gleich die samen da dran packen
rotten flesh kann ich ja auch noch
fressen aber da kriegt man gleich danach
wieder angekommen schmeiße ich weg ich
habe angst vor rotten flesh
das mache ich mir ganz viel holz weil
daraus soll noch ein bisschen mein haus
später bestehen das war so dumm dass ihr
noch aus 26 gemacht habt mushrooms
behalte ich komm ist doch unnötig first
links unnötig unnötig und ich glaube es
gab viel nämlich mit kopper o'barry take
that all das kann man wegschmeißen
ich schmeiße bestimmt gerade die sachen
ganze sachen ihr weg die des todes
wertvoll sind visa green kommt schon mal
wechselt scheiße auf dem bett habe ich
gut kann ich mir einen hinschmeißen
kommt eh nix raus
crafting tables eigentlich auch ganz
nützlich und so jetzt sehen wir hier aus
die besten sachen mit den giants wort
und das dass sie kann nicht darum wieder
wegschmeißen also ich mach das jetzt
gerade eben ganz schnell da kann mich
macht es eben so macht das jetzt mal
eben ganz schnell so grob eben dass die
ganzen sachen eben abbau unserer ganzen
tag weil halt einfach ich jetzt
möglichst schnell eigentlich wieder nach
hause kommen will
die packs nehme ich mir auch mal mit
eine schaufel und dass das sortieren man
gleich erstmal ein bisschen wackeln so
du kommst dahin ist ein sportlich sport
und sport und ich brauche ich nämlich
immer wieder sicherheitshalber mit das
liegt hier noch so alles hast du dir ist
dann kann ich mir erstmal aussetzen
blöder als klitschko oder brauche ich
den ingo für ich weiß es nicht brauche
ich die ganzen sachen wohl später ich
bin mir da wird nicht so liegt noch ein
bisschen diamant was ich auch noch
mitnehmen wollte und hier war auch
irgendwo hatte ich nicht noch eine kiste
aufgestellt ich hab sogar nur eine kiste
aufgestellt oder und ein kräftig aber
den habe ich ja so du bist unnötig mache
ich dazu gold wie sehr gut dann hole ich
mir das auf jeden fall noch ein paar die
männchen da oben sind noch welche ich
unten waren erstmal auch noch welche und
gold muss ich mir auch noch so viel
holen wie es geht weil hier hinten werde
ich wahrscheinlich nie wieder hinkommen
wenn ich da erst mal hinter mein bett
gesetzt hat deswegen kann ich mich jetzt
quasi so bedienen dann den ganzen sachen
hier noch rum liegen und wie gesagt
eigentlich sollte bei sonderfolge auch
ein gast teil dabei sein ich habe zander
gefragt ich habe also zander kommt was
richtig geiles mit sander der könnt ihr
euch so drauf freuen das wird euch so
die lachmuskeln aus dem gesicht reißen
sind richtig heftig geil ist das gold
ist das geld ist das geld es ist gold
und kombis ist nicht gut und es ist auch
nicht gut ich höre verbrennende zombies
auch der hinter mir
naja kann ruhig kommen recht
schallte es über locker easy überlebe
ich das altern albis herd abzug bekommen
ich erschaffe kohle nämlich so viel mit
bis mein stack einfach mal voll ist
ich meine wir wenn wir jetzt schon mal
hier sind dann können wir das natürlich
auch ausnutzen meine lieben freunde
dafür eine dings ist weiß ich gar nicht
das war auch noch gold die reisen und so
habe ich glaube ich nur 20 im inventar
kann ich auch auf jeden fall mal ein
bisschen mitnehmen redstone kann ich die
beiden stacks auch noch voll machen
obwohl redstone ich glaub ich sogar
gleich ein bisschen weg ich meine das
brauche ich ja nicht mal das pack ich
dann lieber noch voll mit eisen und so
einem stoff und dahinter da komme ich ja
nicht ignorieren ich habe erst mal die
diamanten von dieser seite
ich weiß nicht wofür ich mir so ein
pferdchen holen kann
also ich hab mir wirklich ein paar
kommentare die ihr schon geschrieben
habe habe ich mir schon raus notierten
dora skelett kopf habe ich mir schon
schon raus notiert dass ich mir die auf
jeden fall mal angucken muss hier unten
weil er nicht jeden spender spinnen doch
danach gefragt als noch alle tassen auf
jeden fall allerdings bisschen reisen
reifenprofil so hier ist nix bedeutsam
ist noch ein bisschen eisen lapislazuli
helfer habe ich denn die diamanten
gerade noch gesehen
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt so alkohol
diamanten ich bin einfach drüber
gesprungen das weiß oder waren das die
in dieser komischen kluft wird die hier
hinten da doch da war noch welche da
unten waren auch noch welche auf jeden
fall
redstone brauche ich nicht ich brauche
ich im wasser du kommst hier nicht her
bitte so oh mein gott die stoffe mit
richtig riesigen fluss einlauf gut wir
selbst egal sein soll die armen münchen
die haben männchen wie ist das anhört so
hier runter wenn ihr wehgetan gar nicht
wehgetan so ich brauche da hinten
müssten noch auch noch welche ich meine
hier war hier schon warum ist hier bitte
sonnenhaus etf das noch gold überall
ich war so gar nicht jetzt gold wirklich
so wertvoll weil wir hier so viel gold
auftritt dann kann es eigentlich gar
nicht so wertvoll sein
durch braucht halt irgendwo für könnte
mir nochmal schreiben genau wofür ich
mache mir gleich erstmal diese feder mit
gold drum rum da hat einer geschehen
machte man den fehler mit gold drumrum
ich ganz gut wenn man in höhlen ist und
so bei meiner geschrieben da denke ich
mir das schon so schreibt wenn das dann
abgefragt das crafting rezept ist dann
wird dir auch irgendwas cooles sein
hier war aber auch noch irgendwo an die
auf der seite daher werde diamant darum
ist auch noch diamant wo also ich nehme
zu viel diamant mit damit ich mir gleich
einen diamant rüstung machen kann oder
ich glaube es gibt sogar noch bessere
diamant rüstung die man aus diesen
komischen links machen kann
aus diesem meteorit schalen oder wie
heißen so dass alles deckungsgleich auch
voll also ich werde hier nur so auch
genau wir sind wieder bei 8 minuten hier
will ich ich will so locker easy ganz
bisschen aufnehmen hier nur und wir sind
einfach mal wieder bei 8 minuten
hier gehe ich hier einfach hoch dann
setze ich mich ein bisschen so
davon wir meinen ja man kann auch sagen
zwei stück waren hier wieder runter so
schön ein paar staffeln und hier und
hier
so ich werde da oben war sogar noch ein
diamant und ich habe ihn jetzt einfach
übersehen weil ich so hasst dich runter
gelaufen bin dass ein höhle
ich hoffe so komische geräusche immer
und es hakt auch events viel da oben
sind noch diamanten aber kommen die sind
mir scheißegal ist alles zu weit weg da
sind diese komischen steine da oben sind
und die kann ich mir doch eben abgreifen
hier sind ein paar schön das tierchen
wie schön cool
die teile sind nicht feuerbar rückblick
so es wird schon die danach das auf
jeden fall sehr geil
dann werde ich darüber denke ich erst
mal kennen wenn ich darum ankommen
werden diamanten
ich versuche auch übrigens gerade ganze
zeit nicht zu sprinten
wie gesagt grund einfach essen essen
essen essen hier um die womöglich ein
bisschen hoch stecken und hat
ohu richtig viel richtig fette quellen
sind hier am start ja wo ist schluss
sodann stellt hier menschen das bettchen
auto ein schönes mädchen auf scheiße
acht gut ich dachte schon ich sportlich
irgendwo einer luft und fallen dann von
da oben runter übrigens immer wenn ich
diese face cam einstellen
bin ich so supertoll belichtet und jetzt
bin ich dann schon wieder so richtig
künstlich scheiße belichtet obwohl ich
das super eingestellt habe ich verstehe
es nicht
ich kann auf einfach nicht verstehen
setzt hier eine fackel weiter gehe ich
nicht
die haben wie gesagt weiter gehe ich
nicht kenne ist ja auch nicht glaube ich
ich meine wenn ich eine fackel setzte in
der höhle und da sind direkt direkt die
die menschen
ich glaube ich den 37 habe ich schon
daraus werde ich mir auf jeden fall ist
man richtig fette die rüstung machen
richtig geil ich gar nicht runter
ich will jetzt auch keine dann sind
wieder die ammann ich will keine
diamanten mehr sehen ich habe so viele
schon und was ist das hier eigentlich
was ist das ich klickte einmal was ist
das halle berry
ich will nicht es sind alte scheiße
ok ich trau mich jetzt motto ach kann
man sogar so essen ich frag mich in
diesem spiel das ist echt so komisch was
ist hier so alles gibt
so ich töte mich jetzt einfach mal alle
hier
ich brauche jetzt auf jeden fall was zu
fressen anstatt ich schmeiße lieber
redstone beck und hole mir was zu
fressen anstatt hier irgendwie noch so
kacke zu machen dienstag der server im
internet läuft eigentlich gut gerade da
sind auch noch paar scheinchen dich wo
ich auch noch manilas einfach essen mit
wo ich essen kriegen kann
diese teile sind auf jeden fall auf ganz
geil was solchen darf jetzt wegschmelzen
in den rennen in ehren ich glaube dass
den change wo es brauche ich eigentlich
erst mal nicht denn das ist das jetzt so
wenig zugkraft und stone giant spot also
ich kann einfach nur noch einmal drauf
und dann habe ich die schon so und du
bist nur noch deine darunter war auch
noch irgendwo eine zwölf minuten achte
ich will dir ich will mehr schaffen in
der kurzen zeit bruder und auch noch und
du hier auf 12 von diesen teilen also
ich denke wir können wieder sprinten wir
haben eigentlich genug hier noch so
geile sachen als wenn man die wirklich
ein bisschen umguckt und so alles ein
bisschen daraus forscht und das ist ja
auch eigentlich meine spezialität so das
was ich mag so eine hexe dass man halt
nicht nur kräftigen rezepte machen muss
sondern auch so ein bisschen erforschen
mäßig dann ist das schon hammer geil
weil dann kann man so herausfinden so
aber kommt hier die hasen die kann ich
doch töten und dann bekomme ich von den
doch was zu fressen so das ist ein
bisschen wissen auf jeden fall cool
deswegen würde ich jetzt hier die ganzen
schweinchen wollte halt spaß macht ich
mag töten
ich mag töten ich mag töten töten macht
spaß hier um nadu guckt mich schon so
verdutzt an alter du willst doch auch
einfach nur sterben da oben war noch die
diamanten so versprochen dass in die
letzten die ich mir wohl wie komme ich
denn dazu das ist immer so die frage so
oder sind diamanten wie komme ich denn
hin
wisst ihr was ich weiß nicht ich fühle
mich so kacke irgendwie moment findet
ihr das cool wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen
so entdecke so bisschen rumlaufen oder
sagte die bahn ag jetzt endlich mal
deine stadt zurück und macht er da ein
komisches häuschen
könnt ihr mir einmal die kommentare
schreiben welcher kategorie jeder
angehört angehört beziehungsweise worauf
ihr so mehr bock hättet ihr einen
schönen weg bis zu den diamanten dass
sich dann natürlich auch gepflegt hoch
steigen kann so lasst mich mal wo bitter
wäre natürlich wenn jetzt runter fallen
wird und ich werd ich hätte die sache
nicht gezählt bevor das passiert ja ich
das irgendwie so eine falle oder so
hallo gust du dir so viel kohle jetzt
mit wie ich wie das bag noch aushält
also noch 10
doch jetzt eine spitzhacke ist kaputt
ist auf jeden fall will ich aber egal
wir begeben uns auf die heimreise nun
endlich ja nach dieser ganzen vergoldet
dass niemand mit dieser ganzen nicht
wenig sagen vergeudete zeit aber nach
dieser ganzen abenteuerlichen zeit hier
wo ich jetzt 1000 mal gestorben bin ist
der luca nun endlich zur vernunft
gekommen und will jetzt zurück nach
hause gehen würde und frechen jetzt erst
mal von mulberry kann man auch so
schnell fressen das geht so schnell so
und jetzt laufen wir nach hause sind das
überhaupt die richtigen koordinaten
werte ich habe mir koordinaten
aufgeschrieben wo ich hin muss und zwar
schreibe ich das fenster ihr klein
gemacht ich hoffe dass zusätzlich
schlimm und zwar sind das - 4240 sonst
wäre ich jetzt irgendein filter
reingehauen haben oder so dass es besser
ist zu den koordinaten muss ich ihn
laufen
scheiße aber eigentlich 8 kg ich glaube
dass wir das ganze asynchron muss ich
einfach gleich gucken wie das ganze so
weiterläuft
die koordinaten hallo thees - 4240 das
ist in - 4240 auf jeden fall die
richtung und 1533 das ist die richtung
das heißt ich laufe erst mal dahin 800
blöcke bis sich bei der letzten
koordinator 800 also noch 800 lücke da
gerade aus so du bist ja auch noch dein
fleisch
ich meine ich nehme so viel fleisch mit
wie es geht das natürlich klar
die kommen natürlich auch mein herzchen
raus und so das wunderschön alles du
willst du auch deine sachen das sind
schon wieder diamanten geil alter klub
auf dem weg dahin schaffen wir so viele
sachen die in dem kompletten projekt
danach nicht schaffen werden weil wenn
ich wieder in der stadt bin werde ich
nicht trocken zum revier offen da oben
sich auch schon wieder diamanten und
dann werde ich einfach wieder nix packen
können und welche chance angucken wie
weit ich sind ne also wir haben endlich
ganz gute sachen aber ich habe jetzt so
gesehen revie und und wald und manuel
laufen so eine festung zu und gehen
einfach rein und sehen dann in der
festung gegner das natürlich klar was
machen wir was machen die laufen dahin
sehen so das sind gegner dessen gegner
wieder weg dürften solche befinden
werden so unglaublich ich schmeiße ich
noch weg und zwar ein eine spitzhacke so
gemacht natürlich bei mäßig
der luca der tarnung von minecraft
machen natürlich war mäßig hier eine aus
wie heißt ihr wisst ihr bescheid aus
diamant natürlich selbstverständlich
namen sollen diamant überfluss so und du
diamanten ihr fallt nicht ins wasser ihr
kommt zu mir und johnny the journey groß
auf wir müssen immer noch weiterhin die
richtung laufen alter alter alter was
ist das denn bitte
was ist das alter was ist das was ist
etwas ist das für roter stein
red cobblestone junge plötzlich voll
geil eigentlich da sehe ich schon das
ist dass sie durchaus auf jeden fall das
sieht nach einem plus bonus bonus boden
liegt die wir nicht mit mehreren falsch
halte wusste ich dass daraus nichts
gutes wird ich würde sagen das machen
wir erst wenn ich jetzt erstmal meine
sachen alle ein bisschen geschäft ab da
hinten kreis nein lass nach
ob google sich aber noch ein bisschen
leben bitte so wir gehen einfach nach
hause
wir machen keinen stress wir morgen
nicht auf wir wollen einfach nach hause
und sagen ich mache auch gleich direkt
wieder an kati weil wir dürfen nicht
länger als soll er immer so 20 minuten
sein damit die volle noch nicht allzu
lang werden ist ja auch gut erhalten wir
uns natürlich auch dran
deswegen mache ich gleich ganz kurzen
möchte nur eben eigentlich aus diesem
roten blumen aus weil mir das nicht so
ganz geheuer ist aber hätten sich schon
wieder schweinchen und scheint hier sind
mal gut weil schweinchen dort immer was
zu fressen fressen ist echt das wo ich
eigentlich am meisten darauf achten was
ist das hinten so ein runder kaktus oder
soll ich gucke mal ein bisschen rechts
rüber weil der audacity läuft mit der
länge scheiße
wieso bin ich jetzt wieder so weit oben
ich will runter mensch da hinten sieht
es gut aus
schade ich dachte wer mehr ich möchte
einfach mal so mehr so einfach des
homburger zombie aber das sind diese
zombies die nur angreifen wenn man die
an greift also sind diese friede vollen
der wende nur gewalt an
wenn man selbst bedroht wie der mensch
quasi ein normaler mensch wendet nur
gewalt an wenn er halt in einer
notwehrsituation ist sonst sollte man
keine gewalt anwenden so ich habe mir da
jetzt noch eben diese blümchen dann
mache ich ein cut und dann will ich
sagen meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat lasst den daumen hoch da
und dann sehen wir uns direkt der
nächsten folge wieder wo ich dann
weiterhin in richtung stadt laufe